on this vote the
yeas are 228
the nays are 197.
the bill is passed
well there you have it the house has
passed two immigration reform bills
making it easier for dreamers and
migrant farm workers
to become citizens but is this fair to
the immigrants
who came here legally here to weigh in
agnes gibney
a legal immigrant from hungary who
founded
the angel families of america good
morning to you it's so important
to get your perspective on this because
you came here legally
and now as you saw the house just passed
two bills that would make it easier for
folks who didn't come here legally
dreamers and migrant farm workers to get
that citizenship so what are your
thoughts on these two bills
all i can say is this is incredibly
disappointing
we're experiencing the most corrupt
unethical in criminal
democratic congress in the history of
united states
we had already passed
a amnesty bill by reagan
and it has proved to be a total failure
this is a slap in the faces of every
legal immigrant
who follow the laws and a slap in the
face to the millions of americans who
are unemployed
and at a time of a crisis in pandemic
we're bringing more
illegal aliens and allowing them to
bring your
families and aunts and cousins and this
is
not fair this is absolutely
disappointing
yeah well we also have mike diaz joining
us he's a legal immigrant um
he legally immigrated to the united
states from mexico
um as well as emma polla
hansberger we see that you have arrived
as well who
legally immigrated from nicaragua so
mike i also want to get your
take on this because i think everybody
sees the footage of people coming
to this country and their heart does go
out for them because they are
in such a desperate state and they want
to get here so badly
but you immigrated here from mexico
legally so uh what's your take on this
well my take is you know you're
absolutely right
the folks come here want to be want to
be in america and you see this as a land
of opportunity
uh as millions of people have uh
throughout the 200 years
and um but there's a but there's a
process right
and uh and and and it is like the other
speaker
uh was saying it for those of us that
have done it legally
it's kind of a slap slap in the face and
for those that are going through the
process
i'm sure they're very very frustrated
how uh you know they've
done everything right only to have uh
an administration you know open the
border and just allow folks to
to come in and um but really at the end
of the day
uh it's it's it's the problem is a lot
bigger than just
is it a fairness issue and what what i
think about it or what other folks that
are
that are doing it correctly it also
affects many
americans that that may be american-born
right uh
the labor pool um uh for example
gets uh uh you know uh is
is affected by the surge of immigrants
human trafficking where i live in in san
diego county
uh it is a hub for human trafficking and
and so you gotta also look at the at the
human suffrage that's going on
and that's created by some of these
policies uh that's what should be
keeping people up at life at night not
whether
it's fair for me as a as an immigrant
came in
legally but what's happening to those
those those kids
and adults as they are captured in these
nets of human trafficking
as they make their way across
well yeah i think that there is
bipartisan support for
dreamers but you know congressman steve
scalise says that right now as we're
facing such a border crisis
this would send the wrong signal because
then more you know more people will
want to come over and and these two
bills um although they just passed in in
the house will have a more difficult
time in the senate
senator dick durbin did talk about these
bills he said a legislative solution
is long overdue for dreamers who have
devoted their lives to our country
undocumented migrant farm workers doing
back breaking agriculture work
during this pandemic to keep food on our
table and tps recipients
who have built their lives here and are
making essential contributions
to our national recovery emma pola can
you respond to that
yes i'd like to say that it nevertheless
it's uh
insulting to the people that have waited
years to be able to come
and to be um that have gone through the
process of
studying all of the the constitution
the bill of rights the declaration of
independence etc to go through the test
so they can become citizens and be able
to vote
it is a privilege and it is not treated
like a privilege
with this bill they will be able to vote
almost right away
or they can vote illegally and not be
persecuted
i think prosecuted that is and and it's
also
a tremendous um slap in the face for
uh angel moms that have lost children
too
illegal and i know that speaks that that
you know agnes unfortunately is one of
them um
unfortunately we ran out of time and
your perspective
all of your opinions are so important
because i do feel like
the folks who migrated here legally came
here legally are a forgotten part of
this conversation
so thank you so much for sharing your
perspective with us this morning
we appreciate it thank you okay we'll be
right back